( loud chatter
continues )
HA !
I SAID, LOOK...
ENOUGH !
( music stops )
WHAT IS WRONG
WITH YOU PEOPLE ?!
CAN'T YOU BE QUIET
FOR ONE NIGHT ?!
IT'S 1:30 IN THE MORNING
AND I HAVE TO GET UP EARLY
TO GO TO WORK,
DAMN IT !
OH, THIS WHITE BOY'S
TRIPPIN', "YOU PEOPLE ?"
WHAT THE HELL YOU MEAN,
"YOU PEOPLE ?!"
I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A HOUSE MEETING, Y'ALL.
A'IGHT ?
( stomping up stairs )
( Zondra )
THE REASON WHY WE CALLED
THIS HOUSE MEETING IS BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T FEEL SAFE WITH YOU
IN THE HOUSE ANYMORE, CHAD.
ARE YOU SERIOUS ?
I DON'T FEEL SAFE.
WE FEEL AS THOUGH YOU SHOULD
LEAVE, MAN... TODAY.
I SHOULD LEAVE ?
TYREE, YOU--
YOU STABBED MY DAD !
AND YOU HAD SEX
WITH KATIE.
WAIT A MINUTE,
YOU GOT THAT ALL WRONG.
I DIDN'T HAVE SEX
WITH KATIE.
LYSOL HAD
SEX WITH KATIE.
I JUST FILMED IT.
NO, TYREE,
YOU HAD SEX WITH ME TOO.
CORRECTION, I HAD SEX
WITH KATIE.
AND NOW YOU
WANT ME TO LEAVE ?!
I MEAN, REALLY, MAN,
WE COULD JUST FUCK
YOU UP.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE TRYIN' TO BE,
YOU KNOW, COMBENIAL ABOUT THIS.
BUT WORSE
COME TO WORSE,
WE RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
FUCK YOU UP.
RIGHT.
FINE, I--
I GUESS I'LL GO.
HEY, CHAD ?
I HAD SEX WITH KATIE TOO,
MAN.
KATIE HAS
SOME BIG-ASS TITTIES.
( laughing )
♪ OOOOOHHHHHH ♪
♪ AAAHH
OH OH ♪
♪ OH ♪
♪ OOOOOH ♪
♪ GOT THAT FEELING'
OOOHHH ♪
OOOOH ♪♪